These hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
i need to figure out exactly who i am
i want to choose my own path live in the moment
my superheroing days are over
remember what i told you you ever feel lost just
look into the eyes of the people that you love
not me what just listening
Welcome back everyone this will be my thor love
and thunder trailer video marvel finally dropped
a trailer finally there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs obviously they show off
some stuff not everything but we'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos but what's going
on here is that they start the trailer without
any kind of music or anything in a store running
through the woods of old asgard when it was still
around during different ages in his life so like
he starts out as a little kid he's got brownish
hair but then he runs past the tree he's a little
bit older he's wearing the classic walt simonson
classic jack kirby costume like this is old school
thor from the really old comics there's a lot of
later references to that with some of his other
costumes that i'll point out in a second but then
he's a little bit older he's like teenage version
of thor he has a slightly different costume
then he's a little bit bigger and it's before the
events of thor ragnarok before asgard is destroyed
his costume changes to the more modern versions
that we've seen during the infinity saga of
movies a couple different times than the last
one when he's surrounded by fire he's in the
middle of this battle seemingly as he's talking
about how he used to be this god of battle then
we see that he's meditating under this giant
tree that looks kind of like it's meant to
represent the world tree as he buries a version
of mjolnir in the ground to think about his life
this is meant to represent obviously present day
the burning obviously meant to represent with the
way they cut the voice over thor ragnarok and
old asgard burning in the new version of asgard
we do see a version of new asgard as they show
us valkyrie very briefly but one of the coolest
easter eggs here in the different versions of
costumes that they cycle through as he's thinking
about his life is that even later in the movie
he gets another costume change which is inspired
more by rune king thor with a lot of easter eggs
going back to the original costume like it's blue
gold you don't see him wearing the helmet here
but he's wearing the wings again it's going to
be crazy i say rune king thor because a big theme
of this trailer especially at the beginning before
the music track kicks in which is guns n rose's
sweet child of mine the whole thing with thor
thinking about his life is what we basically saw
i need to find out where my place is in the world
that was the whole thing when he left to go with
the guardians we see a montage of him early in
the movie going on a bunch of different battles
to different planets different systems with the
guardians of the galaxy call them the asgardians
of the galaxy you notice that gamora is not with
them because they haven't found that version of
gamora yet or they haven't been able to get her
to come back remember it's gamora from 2014 so
she's not in love with peter quill that's going
to be a big part of guardians 3. that'll all take
place after the events of thor love and thunder
the whole idea that thor is again kind of shirking
his abilities he's actually a legit god in the mcu
a little g god but he's still a god and you have
gorr the god butcher coming along slaughtering all
these mcu guys because he feels like they don't
care about their subjects and that's kind of what
thor has been doing shirking his responsibilities
we've been talking about the mcu gods during the
moon knight series that's going to clarify a
little bit how they exist slightly differently
from the just really powerful cosmic beings
because there are legit gods in the mcu so
part of this movie is thor realizing that he has
a greater cosmic responsibility to the universe
than what he's been doing so far and there's a lot
of trials that he has to go through like odin went
through trials to attain his even greater cosmic
power and become a legit god before he then passed
it on to thor and his children a big part of the
movie is thor going through that as well and then
attaining even more power and becoming even more
responsible as a character when you see the music
track kick in and that funny montage of him as fat
thor just working all that fat off getting back to
being the buff version of thor zoom in enhance
on the hat it actually says strongest avenger
which is a reference to thor ragnarok when tony
stark left the password just to harass him just
to make fun of him a little bit technically he
was able to beat the hulk and the hulk could soak
most of his damage and they could just fight each
other but the whole idea is that as an mcu cosmic
god thor could theoretically gain even more power
than the hulk i'll do a separate hulk videos when
we get to the she-hulk series about how powerful
theoretically they could get but the joke here is
that he starts the workout montage he's working
the fat off you see him in that room with the
skeleton of this giant god-like creature or just
giant creature that looks kind of humanoid one of
the funny things about the trailer you probably
noticed is that as they're playing the music
track and he's thinking about his life talking
to star-lord who seems like he's grown a little
bit wiser since the events of avengers end game
become a little bit more of a leader giving him
some advice about finding what he loves in each of
the different systems that the guardians team goes
to with thor you see them standing amidst this
giant battlefield with a bunch of dead characters
all around them as if doing all this fighting
just comes so naturally to him like he's not even
thinking about like ah this is no big deal that's
just to set up how powerful he is earlier in the
movie before he gets stomped by a version of gord
the god butcher with whatever his version of the
necro sword is going to be called in the movie but
essentially it's the same basic deal like it's a
cosmic power level weapon that allows him to kill
gods because gods don't die the same way that
normal humans die you see him wearing a really
casual looking costume with jeans in a jacket
but it's meant to be this big easter egg for eric
masterson's thunder strike thor because he looked
kind of like the construction worker thor before
he gained the powers of thor but if you couldn't
tell the reason why the jacket is meant to be red
is because right now he's actually being called
ravager's thor like he's part of the ravagers even
though we make a lot of asgardians of the galaxy
jokes and jokes about him leading the team instead
of star-lord leading the team during avengers end
game the t-shirt that he's wearing is actually
an 80s inspired design of the world tree which
is another thor easter egg the belt buckle is also
meant to be a thor easter egg too korg obviously
shows up later in the trailer he has a new belt
too which has the goat horns on it the two ghosts
from the comics actually show up during this too
they call this the goat boat that's right out
of the gorr storyline during the comics too it's
another future tech looking asgardian ship that's
designed to look old-timey that thor uses to fly
around when he's not flying around by himself with
stormbreaker but he is using stormbreaker to open
the bifrost and travel around through cosmic space
whatever just happened he's reunited with korg
and they left him on this planet as he slowly
heads back to asgard if you couldn't tell this is
meant to be a version of new asgard this is him
in the goat boat the goats from the comics aren't
actual goats they're like cosmic beings that have
superpowers that can travel across space but
they look like goats one of the big changes
in new asgard is they become much more of a real
town it seems like they've embraced tourism they
become more like a real actual place in the world
that people could actually travel to and enjoy
and part of the joke here is they just grown
more business-like and valkyrie is getting really
pissed off like she's upset at having to be king
valkyrie or queen valkyrie whatever you want to
call her before gorr the god butcher shows up and
then she has to suit up in her brand new armor too
she actually posted a picture of what she looks
like in her king valkyrie costume because we don't
really see that during the trailer i think part
of the idea with her becoming king is it's more
of a title when it's given to her she wasn't born
of odin so she doesn't have the god level powers
that thor has the backdoor with jane foster thor
is that the magic enchantment that odin put on the
hammer which helps it reform i'll talk about that
in a second too because it's a really big deal
is that odin's enchantment is sort of the
workaround that gives her the exact same
power that thor had or most of the power that he
had when he did that we could call this pirate
thor because it's him just with a bunch of other
women giving you as many funny tropes for the thor
character as possible this could be a completely
different planet but it could just be the outside
of the mount olympus area where the greek gods
live because obviously later in the trailer we
do see a version of zeus who's played by russell
crowe no less it's going to be big celebrity cameo
with his classic lightning bolt i think part
of the idea for introducing him in the movie
is just to give gorr another character to just mow
through so r.i.p zeus russell crowe i don't think
he's going to be in the movie for that long but i
do think that whatever scene he has will be really
cool something to hype up how badass christian
bales gorr the god butcher really is before thor
winds up taking him down if you're not a long time
marvel comic book fan yes a lot of the greek gods
have similar names to the eternals characters who
are also based on a lot of the greek gods a lot of
the other gods too around earth's cultures the way
that mount olympus exists relative to the rest of
the universe is supposed to be similar to the way
that asgard existed relative to the rest of the
mcu marvel's always had a problem in the comics
trying to reconcile all this different mythology
so it's always been a little bit confusing which
is why you don't see a lot of those types of
characters show up but because they're introducing
zeus in the mcu that might mean that they're also
introducing a version of hercules who has
been featured a lot like hercules is a huge
character he's been part of the avengers for a
long time so maybe during the movie they'll wind
up teasing his character they have the funny scene
of thor and star-lord as he's trying to give him
this heart-to-heart talk about looking into the
eyes of what he loves like finding what he loves
but thor is actually looking into star-lord's
eyes as if thor suddenly thinks of him as like
his best friend ever in the time that he's been
with him because he's wearing that new costume
this is obviously right before the guardians of
the galaxy leave on their own and then go off to
a different planet looking for that version of
gamora and thor goes off with korg on the goat
boat on their journey for those of you wondering
because star-lord still does have the dna that's
like half little g god half celestial technically
he would not be on gorr's list because gorr is
looking for the legit gods of the mcu but if peter
quill called himself a god in gorr's presence that
would really piss him off and he probably would
try to kill him technically the celestials are
not little g gods like ego said ego was just
kind of saying that to make himself seem bigger
the celestials are more like super powerful cosmic
beings they're not meant to be legit gods of the
mcu but as you see all these colors fly into the
o of the new version of the logo that's just meant
to represent a version of the bifrost and thor
traveling around using it in stormbreaker with
a goat boat then we finally get a version of jane
foster thor summoning the reformed hammer as thor
just can't believe what's going on in this giant
battle going on around them with gorr's minions
inside new asgard so a couple things here that
they've changed from the comics her costume is
meant to be a little more inspired by the classic
thor costume in classic valkyries costume but
what's going on here is that this is mcu jane
foster who just happens to be visiting asgard when
this happens in the hammer that she's wielding
is the original hammer that hella broke but the
whole idea is that when she broke it physically
she didn't break the enchantment that was on it
based on the other footage that we've seen it just
seems like she's nearby and gorr the god butcher
probably attacks new asgard needs a protector thor
isn't around when that happens jane foster happens
to be visiting the shrine that they built to odin
when he died on the cliff face here because this
is the same area where he died but it also seems
like they basically just erected a shrine around
the pieces of mjolnir if you're wondering how
it's possible to do that because the enchantment's
still on it then technically if you're not
worthy you wouldn't be able to lift the pieces
you could still lift the ground on which the
pieces of mjolnir rest as long as you're carrying
the boulder around and not physically touching
mjolnir you're fine you can carry the hammer
around wherever you want it to go so it just
seems like she physically touches mjolnir when
gorr is attacking and that's enough to activate
the enchantment and reform the hammer and thor is
just witnessing this in new asgard for the first
time in his older brand new costume like he has
a couple different costumes during the movie the
other big thing here too is that they don't really
hide the fact that it is jane foster thor like
the eyes are big enough the mask is big enough
that you can clearly see that it's natalie portman
underneath that armor what they have done though
and this is a big comic book easter egg is that
she normally has brownish hair when she activates
the enchantment it becomes a version of female
thor she has blonde hair so one thor's freaking
out about seeing a version of mjolnir which he
thought was destroyed two he's freaking out about
seeing a version of jane foster who still has
love interest that he hasn't seen in a long time
and three he's freaking out about seeing a version
of her wielding the hammer itself like what is
going on three or four different times but one
of the biggest things that they don't show you is
actual christian bale gorr the god butcher they're
probably gonna say that for the next big trailer
and obviously like i said they did set a record in
how long they waited to release the first footage
of the actual movie it'll also be funny to see if
there's a version of loki from the multiverse that
winds up showing up because it's not quite as much
a multiverse movie as some of the other movies
like doctor strange 2 are but there will probably
be some sort of reference to what's happening
during that because it would be weird to have a
version of a thor movie without a version of loki
i've done a bunch of videos for the movies so
far so i'll link those in the description below
let me know if you spotted any big easter eggs in
the trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
everyone click here for all my other thor love
and thunder videos and click here to learn
about the connection between king the conqueror
and the mcu gods during the moon knight series
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!